feds like definitely more like chill and  can like even be like kind of uh like he  has like a childish like funny side  those jokes and jokes there let's go  funny you know that you know that like  stupid game that you do like you do like  this like yeah you look like he loves it  it was like the thing we were doing in  in Laver cup when I played in like which  is Ryder Cup for tennis yeah and so like  we're a teen world they're over their  team Europe and like feds like we're  trying to do it to fed and fed's like  trying to do it back to us like across  the benches it's like it's like people  would not like expect that from him at  all because but like he's just he's like  that like he's very like classy but then  he also has like a kind of like yeah